desde hace tres generaciones la familia
de Cristina marassicría ganado y produce
leche para el emblemático queso
parmesano en esta granja de la periferia
de parma aquí Los costos de producción
se han disparado en los últimos meses
los precios de los servicios son
aumentado mucho pero también el alimento
para las vacas y las materias primas del
establo han subido espantosamente
para reducir estos costos Cristina ha
decidido como otros ganaderos de la zona
disminuir su número de reses consciente
de que esto reducirá En parte los 17.000
quintales de leche que producía
anualmente hasta ahora
tuvimos que vender algunos animales a
duras penas logramos cubrir el precio
del mantenimiento Y no tiene ningún
sentido tener los animales en el establo
la consecuencia es el aumento del precio
de la leche una mala noticia para Pablo
llenary uno de los 300 productores de
queso certificado parmigiano rellano de
controlado en su fábrica el costo de la
energía triplicó en el último año
tenemos costos de energía importantes
porque usamos máquinas que producen
vapor para cocinar el queso y eso se
hace gracias a unas calderas especiales
el queso producido hoy deberá madurar
durante unos dos años antes de ser
vendido una incertidumbre que preocupa a
Los profesionales del sector esta tarde
en las oficinas del principal sindicato
agrícola del país varios productores han
venido buscando soporte
el riesgo para nosotros es que hoy
sabemos cuánto nos cuesta producir el
queso pero no sabemos Cuál será el
precio de ese queso en 2 años
nuestras empresas están en crisis de
liquidez y no resistirán mucho tiempo
sosteniéndosemejantes costos productivos
rellano producen unos 2 millones y medio
de euros anuales un sector que amenaza
de desplomarse si los precios de la
energía siguen aumentando en Italia